good morning Todd how are you I'm doing
well how's it going everything's good to
meet Friday I've got a Trager girl
myself really yeah yeah actually uh
I love it I love it what's your go-to on
the Trager grill tomahawk steaks okay
all right I like that all right well
done yeah all right
that's all I wanted to talk to you about
Todd thanks for calling in okay did did
Indianapolis the collective NFL heads
there explode when Tyler Murray measured
at 5:10 yesterday a little over 510 I
can't I can't talk about it anymore
[Laughter]
what if he was five nine and seven eight
no difference in my mind I mean I think
I think people were worried maybe five
five eight no no I'm gonna be fine
yeah but what's the difference I mean at
this point the game's changed and I you
know we don't have to go into all of it
but it's more spread out there in the
last 10 years we've never seen
quarterbacks run more throw from outside
to talk get more and in the we've seen
in the last few years a quarterbacks
were six-foot and shorter are actually
having fewer balls batted down
percentage-wise then guys were 6 1 and
taller so you know as long as he's in
the right system and utilized properly I
really I think he's going to be a
dynamic playmaker difference maker and I
think he's gonna have a really good
career yeah I'm right there I've been
sitting in first class on the
window-seat
with Kyler Murray even though I went
through the painful interview with him
that's my big question about him I want
to know who he is as a person I that you
know that I saw the tape I don't care
how his 40 is I saw where some scout was
questioning the velocity and I said Todd
or Todd I I was saying to these guys we
stood next to him as he threw a 20-yard
ball to McLovin and it had as much zip
as
any NFL quarterback we've had on our
show in previous Super Bowls except for
Aaron Rodgers there was no doubt there
was if no yeah yeah no I yeah arm
strength is that's a crazy place to go
with him he has plenty of arm he's got
touch he's he's a lot more accurate and
has a lot better timing as a passer than
people want to give him credit for I do
agree I think the one thing he's the
opposite of of Baker Mayfield he's kind
of quiet to himself yeah some people
who've been around him don't don't
necessarily love them people who have
spent a lot of time with them and worked
with them and guys in that building they
love his his poise and the way he
handles himself and how he's not fazed
by things and how competitive he is I I
think he's a little bit of an acquired
taste I saw that interview that he had
wasn't - and I was I started to get
worried I also don't think he had very
good advice and I don't know what in the
world he was doing outside of making
some money going to the Super Bowl and
doing all those interviews when he
didn't have an answer to what he was
doing yet so yeah it was that was
awkward but I from everyone I've talked
to that's been around him from a
football standpoint I think he's
absolutely has the intelligence to pick
things up but he's not going to be your
rah-rah leader like a Baker Mason if
you're Arizona what are you doing I
guess I got to know what cliff wants
first you know if cliff thinks he and
it's so important to be in line with
your head coach on this see the problem
cliff sees are gonna have to adjust his
system to the NFL a little bit by
putting in more protections in ways for
the quarterback to protect himself
if Josh Rosen is his quarterback because
you can't you can't max out at six-man
protections you can't you know it run
that system the way he has run it in
college with a quarterback that has a
history of injury who's not that you
know begging sick and it is troubling
that trouble staying on the field now if
you have a guy like Tyler who can bail
you know bail you out when protection
breaks down or one you're not in the
right play for the defense
that's where I think the fit is better
and he's also a little bit more of a
point guard a guy who can get the ball
up quickly and work with the tempo that
the cliff's likes to work with so the
fit I understand but it seems it seems
far-fetched to me that they're going to
all of a sudden make this huge deal to
go trade a guy that came in and yeah he
didn't play great but he had nothing
around him last year and he's a top 10
pick and just about everyone I know has
a great higher or equal to what you
would have on Tyler Murray so it's it's
an interesting situation certainly makes
for good television and talk but I just
my guess is at the end of the day my
hunch is that they're gonna stick with
Rosen and move forward yeah but I think
if you're bringing in Kingsbury you're
bringing in a whole different offensive
philosophy and and does Josh Rosen
somehow can you make that fit into what
Kingsbury wants to do I think you can I
think you know it's gonna it's gonna
work both ways and I think Kingsbury I
mean if you look at all the quarterbacks
he's had they haven't always been mobile
I mean that Texas Tech system hasn't
always been you know built for mobile
quarterbacks look at the Kingsbury
himself but I think what it does is it
provides it provides that extra layer of
protection if if you're able to get out
of the situation by running and Rosen
can't I mean Rosen's two biggest issues
or he's not he's not overly mobile and
he's that trouble saying how other than
that he's you know he's exceptional as a
passer he's the best pure passer of that
group a year ago so I I think it can
work but I it's the only reason I'm
going down there mentally down that road
mentally is because I think Tyler's a
better fit for what Kingsbury has always
done compared to roasts
how many quarterbacks if I gave you
over-under three and a half first-round
I take under I take under but I so I
think it'll be three I think I think
guru Lak from Missouri winds up getting
in just because it's quarterbacks Daniel
Jones is not is not what everyone's
think he is
I think he's more of a third round or
backup in the week I see the
intelligence and all that but you study
his tape Duke he's he he's very average
he's just very average everything's a
short throw he's inconsistent with his
accuracy don't throw the ball down the
field a lot he give him credit he's
tough as nails
when he takes off running he's
surprisingly good speed but he's not
very you know twitchy and agile in the
pocket so he takes a lot of hits and his
offensive line is terrible but he takes
a lot of hits too and I don't know I
just I don't see the fourth guy you know
Jared Stidham from Auburn has talent and
I think if he's utilized properly unlike
what happened at Auburn I think he can
have success in the league but he's a
developmental project so to me it's it's
kind of Emery it's Dwayne Haskins and I
think I think drew Locke because of the
quarterback position will wind up going
in the first round somewhere who's your
favorite player that in five years
you'll say I told you so
that's a good question I think Marquis
Brown is the wide receiver from Oklahoma
is a special unique difference-maker I
know he's in a boot right now I know he
has an injury I hope no he's only 166
pounds and it's going to be an issue
throughout his career but when that dude
is on the field I haven't seen many guys
like him in terms of clay speed I mean I
think DeSean Jackson is the perfect
comparison in terms of NFL guys and what
he can be when when when they're both
healthy you know the ability to create
after the catch and then get vertical
you can hand them the ball off and
there's so many different ways that he
could burn you and he's in today's NFL
his ability to get open so quickly I
just think he's going to be special
the reaction in Indianapolis when Jason
Witten decided to leave the booth
shocked I don't even know how much I'm
allowed to say here but I know I was
standing next to Adam Schefter when he
was on on the TV I was with a whole lot
of people from from this company and
there wasn't one person I was with that
had any idea that it was going to happen
now I I get
I understand that it was a frustrating
year for him but I never even worked
with him at the national championship
game I worked with the Monday night crew
at the national championship game on
that mega cast the whole night never I
mean not that he wouldn't was the first
time we've met so not that he would give
me any indication but it seemed like he
was very much into the broadcast gig and
and was was really intelligent like just
talking football with him he really
really understood more than I think
people probably got from watching the
broadcaster's at times but but um I
think you got frustrated I think he but
how much of this though Todd is that
social media Judy mom as an analyst was
he looking for an escape route yeah we
think it's part of it yeah I but I also
do you know and I've talked to people
now who have been around them and and
there he was looking at the possibility
of going back to the Cowboys in the
middle middle of the year last year so I
think it he never quite fully mentally
gave it up I think part of the reason he
left because he thought I hey I'm never
gonna how am I going to get this
opportunity again Monday Night Football
you know but I don't think he had closed
the door mentally even though he tried
to talk himself into it so but I do
think the social media part was a
significant factor and I think if this
season went great and he got the kind of
reaction that Romo got or even just a
normal reaction I think I think he'd
still be back in Monday Night Football
that's interesting
yeah because I'm wondering about Greg
Olson I was told by somebody who's
familiar with with Olson situation that
he thought Olson was going back to the
Panthers and not gonna put himself out
on the market there for Fox or ESPN what
are you hearing about Greg Olson I've
heard nothing I'm more focused on
offensive lineman running sub 5-second
40s right now I need I need some new
jargon because you guys come up with you
know waste bender and all this stuff we
we heard lower body twitch from Daniel
Jeremiah do you got a you got another
one here we can keep an eye on here with
combine in the draft when you're
watching the defensive backs on Monday
and you're watching them turn and open
their you know open up
yeah wheelie hips you go to Jiffy Lube
and get oily hips I think they're like
well Todd have fun this weekend and we
appreciate your time as always
of course that's Todd McShea the
mothership and they got the NFL Scouting
Combine Trey hang a Wingo will host
it'll be Saturday March 2nd at 1:00
Eastern it's a two-hour special on ABC
so you got Adam Schefter Chris Mortensen
Louis Redick and Todd McShea for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]